- In our very first
episode, we recommended
buying a used car with cash
as the most financially sensible option.
- But for many people,
that's just not possible.
The majority of Americans
finance their vehicles
with loans, and with rising
prices and rising interest rates
car loans are getting
more expensive than ever.
- [Julia] The average interest
rate on a new car jumped
from 4.4% to 7% in just the last year.
The amount that Americans
now owe on cars has doubled
since 2011, making up over
9% of total US consumer debt.
- You'd think that this
might be a good time
to forego buying and lease a car instead.
No debt, no commitment,
and lower monthly
payments than a car loan.
- They can seem attractive at first,
but lease agreements have
plenty of financial pitfalls,
and are just as vulnerable
to price and interest
rate hikes as buying.
- They're not always a bad idea.
Ultimately, it depends
on what matters to you,
and how much you're willing to pay for it.
(jaunty music)
- The fundamental
misconception about car leases
is that they work like
other rental agreements,
like for apartments or furniture.
They don't.
Cars are a unique asset
for one ugly reason:
Depreciation. Nothing costs so
much yet loses value so fast
as a car, except maybe
timeshares or bitcoins,
and lease agreements are
designed to account for that.
- Here's how it works.
If you wanted to lease a
new car for the typical term
of 36 months, the dealer
will take the selling price
of the vehicle and subtract
what it's predicted to be worth
in three years, known as the residual.
The result is essentially
the depreciation,
how much value the car will lose
while it's in your possession,
which you are required to pay
off in monthly installments.
But here's the kicker.
That amount is treated like a debt.
Just like a car loan,
you'll pay interest and fees
determined by your credit score,
and often be required to
put up a down payment.
- In this way, a car
lease is less of a rental,
and more like buying
the most expensive years
of a car's life.
And because they depreciate so quickly,
that can be close to half its total value.
True, it's less than the sticker price.
So your monthly payments are lower
than a car loan would be
for an equivalent vehicle,
but when the lease is up, you
have no asset to show for it.
- Some lease agreements
allow you to buy the car
at the end of the term
at its residual price,
but because leases tend to have
higher fees than car loans,
you'll end up paying more than if you had
just bought it outright to begin with.
- Another supposed advantage
of leasing a car is the freedom
it affords. For those who
are scared of commitment,
it can seem exciting to swap
vehicles every few years,
but leasing comes with its
own set of restrictions.
- First of all, most lease
agreements have a mileage limit
for the term of the lease,
usually between 12,000
and 15,000 miles per year.
And if you go over that, you'll pay extra
at a rate as high as 50 cents per mile.
You can opt for a higher mileage limit,
for a higher monthly payment of course,
and you will not be reimbursed
for any miles you didn't use.
- Second, you must return the vehicle
exactly how you received it.
So don't bother upgrading the stereo,
or installing custom rims,
unless you don't mind
reinstalling the old ones
before you bring it back.
- And lastly, lease
agreements are notoriously
hard to get out of.
Early termination incurs
penalties that are sometimes
as much as the total
remaining balance all at once.
And unlike car owners, you
can't just sell the vehicle
if you don't want it anymore.
You're pretty much stuck with
it until the term is over.
- To be fair, there are some
advantages to leasing a car.
Many lease agreements include
routine maintenance costs,
and newer cars are typically still
under a manufacturer's warranty.
That's no small thing,
considering car repairs
are one of the most common
unexpected financial crises
people have to deal with.
You'll never have to go through
the hassle of selling it.
And if you own a small business,
leasing a car can offer big tax benefits.
Unlike car loans, in which you
can only deduct the interest,
lease payments by businesses
are fully tax deductible.
- But the main appeal of leasing
is largely psychological:
having access to a nice, new, reliable car
that you otherwise
wouldn't be able to afford.
The benefits of comfort,
status, and safety
may not be financial,
but that doesn't mean they're worthless.
What's the point of money
if it can't make us happy?
- But are they worth enough
to overcome the cost?
- I think it's time to-
(together) run the numbers!
(triumphant music)
- [Julia] Michael and Ali are
both in the market for a car,
and each has room in
their budget for around
500 to 600 bucks a month, with
the same good credit score.
Ali decides to buy a used car for $20,000.
He puts $3,000 down, and ends up
with 36 monthly payments
of about 540 bucks.
- [Phillip] Michael wants
something fancier, so he decides
to lease a new car with a
selling price of $40,000,
which will lose about 40% of its value
over the three year term.
He also puts down $3,000, and
including interest and fees,
he'll end up paying about
$580 a month for 36 months.
- [Julia] At the end of three years,
both men have paid roughly
the same amount of money,
but their financial situation
couldn't be more different.
Ali now owns his car free
and clear, and he can sell it
for probably half to two
thirds of what he paid for it,
or he can drive it until it falls apart,
which could be five to 10 years from now,
depending on how well he caress for it.
- [Phillip] Michael, on the other hand,
is right back where he started.
Instead of buying out
the residual for $24,000,
he opts to lease another new
car under the same terms.
If we fast forward another three years,
Michael will have paid
about $25,000 more than Ali.
After a total of nine years,
even if Ali has had to shell out $10,000
in maintenance and repairs,
he'll still be almost
$40,000 ahead of Michael.
- Now, Michael isn't paying
that money for nothing.
He gets to tool around town
in a brand new ride
with all the amenities.
Whether that's worth it
depends on what matters to you.
But generally speaking,
if you can't afford
to buy a new car, you
probably can't afford
to drop $40,000 on a luxury, either.
- At the end of the day, inflation
and rising interest rates
haven't changed the math on leasing.
- If you have a car in working order,
take good care of it, and drive
it for as long as you can.
And if you're in the market for a vehicle,
buying, even with a car loan,
still makes the most financial sense.
- Leasing provides the short-term benefit
of driving a nicer car for lower payments,
but you're not solving a
problem, just buying time.
(together) And that's our two cents.
- Thanks to our patrons
for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a Two Cents patron.
Our very first episode still holds up.
Check out "How Cars Keep You Poor."
(jaunty music)